[Musique]
stéphanie chouinard jonathan trudeau
michel david bonsoir bonsoir on revient
au pays
le débat jonathan c'est votre sujet
préféré de la fin des mesures d'urgence
puis les arcanes de qu'est-ce qui est
prévu qu est-ce qui est pas prévu joe
faire entendre monsieur dubé que s'il te
plaît dit ce matin fait est mal reçue
hier pourquoi parce que le projet de loi
que le gouvernement dépose et prévoit
une fin par étapes on écoute tout ça
pour vous
on refera mine pendant longtemps qu'on
enlève les mesures d'urgence et à la
première occasion qu'ont faits
démontrent je vais rester très polis
soit leur incompréhension du projet de
loi ou même peut-être leur imprudence en
ce moment il ya encore 60 décret qui
sont écris moi ce que j'ai demandé au
ministère si les prochains jours vous
allez me ramener ça à trois ou quatre
décrets ça va devenir très clair qu'on
peut pas rajouter tous ces éléments sont
techniques c'est dans huit articles de
loi alors va offrir aux oppositions le
au plus tard lundi ou mardi prochain un
briefing technique pour expliquer
l'opposition a répété toute la journée
le vam avait un chèque en blanc ça
fonctionne pas ailleurs au canada il ya
longtemps à lever l'état d'urgence un
plan jonathan jeannette ou là d'un
match mal fait son travail il avait bien
mis la table il y a quelques semaines
lors entre autres d'entrevues de chef de
cabinet martin koskinen qui avait pour
la première fois évoqué ce scénario de
dépôt d'un projet de loi pour mettre fin
à l' urgence sanitaire mais il a eu le
mal préparé le terrain pour la plupart
des personnes concernées les partis
d'opposition les syndicats et cetera
cette notion lot d'associer la fin
d'urgence sanitaire un date précise le
31 décembre 2022 c'était du nous il n'y
avait pas eu de signaux qui avait été
fait en ce sens là un projet de loi
qu'on a voulu faire très simplement
quitter sur quatre pages incluant la
page couverture mais qui était peut-être
trop simple je pense qu'on aurait pu
être plus précis parle exactement de son
ce qu'on voulait conserver comme pouvoir
moi j'ai trouvé qu'il sert du bisse
matin ils étaient plus claires meilleur
je pense que ça a été un exercice plutôt
périlleux pour le gouvernement et ses
fans et jonas est vrai qu ailleurs sauf
erreur on l'a pas gardé on n'a pas gardé
des plans 2d disposition des mesures
d'urgence non non on ne gouverne plus
par décret en ontario depuis un bon bout
de temps déjà les mesures sanitaires
étaient toujours en place et commence à
tomber depuis un mois et à lundi
prochain au lendemain finalement de
notre congé du mois de mars les masques
ne seront plus obligatoire la distension
distanciation social non plus mais ça
fait longtemps que les députés de
l'opposition à queen's park ont repris
leur travail comme comme d'habitude bon
chef david pourquoi ils font ça parce
qu'ils voudraient pas madame anglade est
allé d'une hypothèse ce matin en disant
qu'il ne voudrait pas cet automne
remettent des décrets ce qu'ils
pourraient tout enlevé puis remettre des
chris paul ont commencé expliqué ce qui
se passe ou et écoutez c'est un débat
qui est fondamental en démocratie qui
passionne les parlementaires mais je
pense pas que la population soit elle me
suivent tellement ce débat là ce qui est
important pour les gens s'il ya dessus
des mesure où il n'y a pas de mesure
quelle est la mécanique derrière ça ce
que ce décret ce que c'est un dépôt à
l'assemblée nationale je pense la
population se préoccupe pas de ça
tellement et s'il y avait une sixième
vague par exemple et que le gouvernement
devrait introduire des mesures center
c'est pas par un nouveau décret ou
pourrait activer le décret ans et ça
fait pas une grande différence au cloud
opinion publique alors je ne pense pas
que ce soit nécessairement ça mais il se
garde oui une marge de manoeuvre ce qui
est disons raisonnable pour un certain
nombre de choses en cas de sixième vague
mais mais pour le reste je pense pas que
savoir faire
grand débat au sein de la population
maintenant pourquoi le gouvernement a
tant tardé par rapport à ailleurs je
pense que la résistance aux mesures
sanitaires a été beaucoup moins forte au
québec qu'ailleurs et le gouvernement
s'est senti beaucoup plus
libres de continuer d'une manière qui
évidemment façon à faire parce qu'il
décrète il n'y a pas de débat mais sur
le fond je pense que pour la population
c'est pas une question très importante
le
comment ça fonctionne ouais c'est ce
qu'un peu bien ce que vous aviez dit
jonathan l'autre fois en dix ans que
pour le commun des mortels à moins qu'on
découvre que dans des contrats de gré à
gré on a donné des contrats des gens
qu'on n'aurait pas dû de ce genre de
faire là assurément mais moi j'aime bien
par les dieux du test de la machine à
café et l'urgence sanitaire ne pas
politiser la machine à café c'est quoi
ce c'est essentiellement de quoi les
gens parlent autour de la machine à café
ou au travail surtout qu'ils ont
recommencé à se côtoyer un peu plus sur
les lieux de travail de quoi il parle
autour de la machine à café en ce moment
il parle assurément de la guerre en
ukraine ils parlent les fellahs
l'inflation l'augmentation du coût de la
vie mais est ce que vraiment ils se
disent moi je suis sorti chez moi ce
matin là et chanter le poids de
l'urgence sanitaire sur mes épaules dont
ça s'est passé donc oui à des principes
démocratiques et michel le disait bien
on doit s'assurer que le gouvernement
rende des comptes nabe aux pommes et au
delà des sommes aussi j'étais à la place
des partis d'opposition je perdrais pas
trop de temps là-dessus je pense que
d'autres problèmes plus plus criants
surtout à six mois des élections n'est
pas certain que c'est comme ceux qui
vont gagner de précieux points
politiques dont ils ont besoin oui même
si stéphanie je pense c'était vous qui
étaient là dedans vous deviez sa touche
à des principes importants pour pas les
perdre de vue mais ça peut vite devenir
un débat et intérêts le décret projet de
loi ou pas si le gouvernement doit ré
imposer des mesures à l'automne comme
dit michel il va le faire d'une façon
d'une eau oui oui tout à fait d'accord
avec avec michel là dessus que bon on
peut parler des grands principes et en
tant que politologue évidemment ça vient
me chercher je pense que c'est important
d'assurer que quel que l'opposition est
tous les outils nécessaires pour faire
son travail pour s'assurer que le
gouvernement rende des comptes mais
monsieur madame tout le monde ne voit
pas ça au jour le jour on va de toute
façon entendre madame anglade sur la
scène publique s'il ya quelque chose qui
se passe et donc j'ai pas l'impression
le que ça vaut la peine pour
l'opposition de s'acharner éternellement
sur cet enjeu particulier bon passons
notre sujet alors la cour ch
conservatrice on va voir des images de
publicité de pierre poilievre qui
vraiment est d'agen il dans un ring de
boxe il en laisse pas passer une bombe
dans monsieur charest est un libéral
sont le vu passer ces écrits dans ciel
monsieur brown aussi l'attaqué sur le
sur la taxe carbone est sûre il a
demandé des taxes c'est encore la
publicité pour monsieur charest je fais
entendre
monsieur mulroney qui est venu mettre
son grain de sel c'est pas un appui à un
candidat mehdi en tout cas vous allez me
dire ce que vous en pensez ça ressemble
pas mal à une attaque contre deux sur
poilievre quand même on écoute
et le monde se disent vos neurones les
épaules il me
regarde les 90 fils byron
irak frauder
[Musique]
je vous ramène à monsieur marc launay
qui dira la politique à coups de
poubelle s'est terminé ces familles
quand qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé
mais c'est certain que sans le dire
monsieur montbronnais parle évidemment
des campagnes des attaques de pierre
poilievre vis-à-vis de ses adversaires
jusqu'à maintenant monsieur poilievre
depuis qu'il est entré dans la campagne
fait une campagne extrêmement agressive
bon l'année dernière il s'est appelé
lui-même le pitbull du parti
conservateur et on voit que dans cette
campagne là il apporte ce ton là
c'est extrêmement agressif et c'est
certain que dans le cadre d'une course à
la chefferie au sein d'un parti où on
sait il ya déjà des franges qui sont pas
d'accord que théologiquement sur un
paquet dangereux et où au lendemain de
la course à la chefferie il faudra
retrouver une certaine unité lorsqu'on
fait de la politique de la terre brûlée
ben ça peut laisser des marques qui va
falloir panser les plaies au lendemain
de la course à la chefferie et à cet
égard là monsieur poilievre est
peut-être en train de se faire des
ennemis otan qui se fait des amis je
n'attends que ça l'est du chat lui nuire
poilievre ben moi je pense que c'est lui
nuit et par un instant de stratégie pure
et simple parce que oui le camouflet
reçu leur journée à la base ne l'aide
pas mais le fait qu'il est attaqué de
façon frontale patrick blanc ou jaune au
jour 1 de l'annoncé de sa candidature en
le traitant carrément de menteur qu'est
ce que vous pensez qu'il fait il le dit
à tous les militants de patrick brown
tous les sympathisants patrick brown je
serai certainement pas votre deuxième
choix lors du fameux vote préférentiel
il aurait dû plutôt essayer ça descende
il est courtisé de dettes une
alternative pour ces gens là parce
qu'ultimement si tous les militants les
sympathisants patrick brown 10 capes au
lièvre notre candide notre homme au jour
1 il a attaqué sauvagement le traitant
de menteur certainement pas pour lui
qu'on va voter alors qu'ils vous pensé
se réjouit tout seul je vous le confirme
jean charest se frotter les mains en
zappant dans les deux sens les deux
candidats s'accusent mutuellement moi je
vais potentiellement récolter des
deuxième vote et c'est ce qu'ils
cherchent aussi à ce moment michel web
un jeu temps c'est assez clair que c'est
un appui est à peine église et à
monsieur charest kaki et son fils
spirituel là dedans et monsieur charest
souvenez-vous au tout début de la
campagne lui a dit d'entrée de jeu
exactement ce que monsieur mulroney a
dit moi je n'attaquerai pas mes
adversaires je vais exposer ma vision du
canada essentiellement c'est ce que
monsieur moindre onidi maintenant
monsieur poilievre lors on changera pas
la bbc comme ça et même si jonathan a
parfaitement raison c'est
contre-productif peu importe qui est
comme ça et peut-être je sais pas
jusqu'à quel point il mesure que vous
savez les policiers professionnels quand
la bataille est finie bon ben on ferme
les micros et puis là on serre la main
mais les partisans ça marche pas comme
ça cependant si les pompes comme ça
pendant six mois ils pourront pas le
lendemain c'est beau mais tous derrière
choix au reste c'est lui qui gagne alors
le risque est très certain de fractures
d'une vraie fracture d'une vraie
fracture maintenant faut quand même sens
temps d'une course au leadership
c'est pas une bataille de dentelle il y
en a des coups bas dans tout l'est dans
toutes les courses souvenez-vous de la
course de 2013 au parti libéral du
québec quand raymond bachand avait
ressorti les accointances de philippe
couillard avec
porter
ça fait fait grincer pas mal au sein du
parti libéral et je pense pas d'ailleurs
que ça a été à l'avantagé monsieur
bachand et d'ailleurs mais monsieur marc
launay lakic vesoul il a été un homme
d'état dans les premières un peu mais à
l'époque sa deuxième course à la
chefferie les couches de neige ça des
gros congrès traditionnels puis ce n'est
pas non plus la dentelle ses fans il
non c'est certain que on voit qu'il ya
déjà eu de l'animosité et c'est normal
je pense que ce que monsieur moroni et
ça y est à dire c'est que là on tombe
dans des attaques personnelles un peu
comme j'en attends le disait de pas
nécessairement le dire je suis pas
d'accord vous c'est les idées de mon
adversaire sont pas valables pour
raisons x y z on appelle quelqu'un de
menteur on est en train de dire ce
personnage devrait complètement
disqualifié de la course et donc on est
dans une on est dans un autre type de
discours est bon c'est un type de
discours auquel monsieur poilievre nous
habituer clairement il doit voir que ce
type 2 le discours là ça fonctionne on
prête ses partisans et je me demande
jusqu'à un certain point ci n'est pas en
train de s'enfermer dans sa propre boîte
en jouant ce type de politique l'eau et
en n'étant pas capable finalement de
changer de caisse et de paddy sio nez
des gens qui très rapidement vous 3
j'entendais respect dans l'analyse qu'on
attendait beaucoup c'était le début de
monsieur charest n'a pas été très bon
les réseaux sociaux sont prêtés travaux
jeudi soir et à calgary
qu'en pensez vous michel je commence
avec vous rapidement et après je
n'atteins ces familles ben monsieur
charest avant l'ère houllier c'est vrai
et on sait que c'est un homme
de la décennie précédente
dans sa technique maintenant sur le fond
je pense que monsieur charest je voyais
encore salle est par exemple sur les
dépenses militaires et le rôle que le
canada devrait jouer je pense que au fur
et à mesure où la course va se
développer ils vont élaborer une vision
qui va aller au delà des petites
chicanes et
le temps va le servir de ce point de vue
là jonathan
monsieur charest dutil pas prendre son
erre d'aller tranquillement c'est sûr
que le fait d'avoir eu la cote et
d'aujourd'hui ça freine un peu l'élan
qu'il tentait de se donner mais là ils
vont occuper davantage de terrain va
être entre autres au québec plus présent
dit on vers la fin de la semaine
prochaine donc suivons le suivant l'âge
et stéphanie
la première vidéo de lancement a été un
peu bobo on s'est demandé pourquoi il a
ressorti sa vidéo 2020 mais la campagne
est longue donc il a le temps amplement
de se reprendre
merci beaucoup à vous trois très bons
merci au revoir bientôt pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh